[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta que en esta ocasión nos
lleva a Turquía tras 20 años de la
creación del akp el partido y su líder
recepta y erdogan han acabado haciéndose
hegemónicos en el país controlando la
política la economía la religión y los
medios de comunicación
erdogan es la cara del país desde hace
20 años Fue Primer Ministro y luego
presidente ha superado Incluso en
longevidad al fundador de la República
turca mustafa kemal ataturk y ha seguido
los pasos que ha dejado para la Turquía
moderna al tener una imagen de hombre
del pueblo y de hombre de fe Bajo su
poder se han construido más de 15.000
mezquitas en Turquía desde 2002 también
carreteras cárceles escuelas y
hospitales sus partidarios afirman que
ha transformado Turquía y que también ha
reforzado enormemente El poder del
presidente pero para sus oponentes
erdogan Es sobre todo el hombre que ha
sofocado toda disidencia amordazando a
la prensa debilitando el poder judicial
los procesos democráticos y también ha
hecho triunfar la religión pasando por
encima del laicismo de la República
turca en estos 20 años la vida de todos
los turcos ha cambiado profundamente
nuestros corresponsales en Turquía
conocieron a dos de ellos tienen más o
menos la misma edad y viven en la misma
zona cerca de Estambul uno de ellos ha
abierto un negocio exitoso y el otro ha
sido procesado encarcelado e incluso ha
perdido su trabajo son dos bandos en el
mismo país Esta es la historia
a pocos kilómetros de la costa de
Estambul en pleno Marte mármara se
extiende un archipiélago de nueve Islas
la isla de Los Príncipes donde hace
mucho tiempo Los emperadores bizantinos
Caídos fueron condenados al exilio en la
actualidad las Islas se utilizan
principalmente como segundas residencias
los habitantes de Estambul van allí de
paseo a Sólo una hora en barco desde el
bósforo al llegar a huyucada la isla
principal Los viajeros son recibidos por
la única oficina del partido
presidencial en el archipiélago
aunque las Islas forman parte del
municipio de Estambul el partido
gobernante el akp nunca ha ganado unas
elecciones aquí
ni siquiera cuando recepta giberán fue
alcalde en la década de 1990
Hola
Bien y usted
erdem fue elegido Hace cuatro años con
un partido de la oposición
cuando el akp llegó al poder su lema era
lucharemos contra la corrupción la
pobreza y las restricciones esta era su
línea Roja en aquel momento Turquía lo
necesitaba
pero eso fue hace 20 años
hoy Turquía se enfrenta a más corrupción
pobreza y restricciones que nunca
al menos en comparación con los 40 50
años anteriores
están por todas partes
el ex periodista de 55 años se vio
directamente afectado por estas
restricciones
en un artículo publicado el 29 de mayo
de 2015 en el conocido diario Juliette
el antiguo jefe de la oficina de ankara
detallaba la munición enviada al frente
sirio en convoyes secretos de armas
turcas Poco después erdén fue acusado de
publicar documentos confidenciales y
propaganda de una organización
terrorista entre otras cosas
como decenas de otros periodistas turcos
erten ha cumplido condena en la cárcel
todo el mundo paga el precio en Turquía
yo personalmente pasé 92 días en la
prisión de silivry no lo veo como algo
especial Esto no es más que el resultado
de nuestra lucha por la democracia en
Turquía en el pasado sucedía lo mismo
hoy en día ocurre con más frecuencia
también vio cambiar su vida bajo el akp
pero en sentido contrario
este cocinero propietario de un
restaurante de kebabs En una isla
cercana burgazada se ha convertido en un
ferviente admirador de su presidente
créeme rezo por erdogan en la oración de
la mañana
Digo toma mi vida y dásela a él Le juro
que es verdad
cuando me acuesto por la noche también
rezo por él
desde que abrió su restaurante café
cardesh el café de los hermanos hace 15
años
ha trabajado duro y ha podido recoger
los frutos de su trabajo un mejor nivel
de vida en su pueblo no es el único que
denuncia estas expropiaciones
todos los empresarios han beneficiado
esta estabilidad incluido yo
todos los empresarios han comprado un
auto o un apartamento Nadie puede decir
lo contrario
Nadie puede decir que no ha podido
comprarse una casa o un auto en los
últimos 20 años
[Música]
a finales de los 90 todos teníamos autos
viejos ahora todo el mundo tiene un auto
nuevo Yo también Compré uno Gracias a mi
trabajo también compré un apartamento
sin embargo la actual crisis económica
frena el desarrollo Turquía tiene la
tasa de inflación más alta de los países
del g20 oficialmente superior al
85%, los precios se disparan los turcos
recurren masivamente al crédito la
situación recuerda a la de finales de la
década de 1990 cuando el akp llegó al
poder magnet cree que ciertoán fue capaz
de cambiar las cosas hace 20 años puede
volver a hacerlo
por qué no nos quejamos de la inflación
porque en el pasado hemos tenido buenos
años
y que hoy tenemos que sufrir nos
complace llevar parte de la carga de
nuestro presidente
una carga que cada día se hace más
pesada
a recorrer su circunscripción el tem
siempre escucha la misma queja de los
comerciantes
los precios suben y suben rápido
los precios han subido un 35% en el
último mes Sí 35% en un mes Caramba el
alcalde de la oposición se niega a
acusar abiertamente al partido
gobernante ante las cámaras
debo decirle que hace poco el gobierno
dijo que la inflación bajará a partir de
enero
Pero según este comerciante usted espera
una baja en enero
No porque no hay nada que lo indique no
hay motivos para esperar un descenso
mientras que la kpr redujo la tasa de
pobreza en un 30% sus primeros 15 años
en el poder se ha disparado desde 2018
el precio de los productos lácteos
puede decirte lo mejor que yo
digo estos productos son para el
desayuno ahora en Turquía hay familias
que no pueden comer por la mañana
los alumnos van a la escuela con el
estómago vacío
Este es el final del día para mehmet
en invierno los turistas son escasos
Puede irse a casa antes de la hora de
cenar
[Música]
la travesía a la parte asiática de
Estambul duró unos 40 minutos
[Música]
una vez que recupere su auto le resta
media hora más de trayecto
[Música]
cada tramo del recorrido tiene la huella
de erdoan
todo lo que ves son proyectos de la kp
todas estas flores miren estos jardines
al borde de la carretera lo hicieron
No se pasaron el tiempo hablando y sin
hacer nada la carretera sancha hay
flores a ambos lados está limpia
el municipio del Gran Estambul pasó a la
oposición en 2019 pero aquí el distrito
sigue en manos del partido presidencial
bloques de apartamentos mezquitas y
centros comerciales el paisaje típico de
la Urbanización que quiere el akp
la paz sea con ustedes Bienvenidos
mehmet es un cocinero profesional
pero en casa de su esposa y brille quien
prepara las comidas
en el menú platos tradicionales del mar
Negro
al igual que erdoan la familia procede
de la pequeña ciudad de Rise
siempre estamos orgullosos de nuestro
presidente ahí perdón y más aún porque
venimos del mismo lugar
esta noche la familia estará completa
zeynep israh vinieron con sus hijos
ambas jóvenes están casadas y son amas
de casa
[Música]
como se suele ocurrir se habla de
política en la mesa
por supuesto no siempre estamos de
acuerdo hablamos del partido a veces
discutimos con mi padre y me echa de
casa
entre los temas de discordia está el
número de extranjeros que huyen de la
guerra o la pobreza para instalarse en
Turquía
desde el inicio de la guerra en Siria en
2011 más de 3,5 millones de refugiados
han llegado al país
de los 16 millones de habitantes de
Estambul casi dos millones son
extranjeros
tengo un hijo algún día será adulto
Ojalá y sus compañeros fueran turcos
pero cuando vas a la escuela hay afganos
árabes gente de todo el mundo también
sirios esto es bastante normal Sí claro
pero ahora es demasiado están por todas
partes no sea racista Es cierto que hay
muchos Creo que deberían ser enviados a
casa una vez que su país haya
solucionado sus problemas
como cabeza de familia mehmed considera
que su papel es educar a sus hijas sobre
la política del akp Respecto a los
refugiados Especialmente los sirios
los sirios son nuestros hermanos y
hermanas mis hijas lo entenderían mejor
si conocieran la historia los verían
como hermanos y hermanas si no abrimos
las puertas qué les pasará nuestro
vecino inmediato tiene un problema es
mejor no intervenir no abrirles las
puertas Por supuesto que no por supuesto
como soy joven discutimos con mi padre
sobre esto porque en el pasado ha visto
ciertas cosas con las que no puedo ser
una comparación
veo las cosas como son por eso existe un
conflicto con las generaciones mayores
porque cuando voy por la calle miro
izquierda y derecha tengo miedo
otro tema que preocupa mucho a las dos
hermanas es la violencia contra las
mujeres que ha empeorado bajo el ácape
[Música]
tengo miedo al acoso ahora cierro mi
casa con llave y cuando salgo no quiero
mezclarme con la multitud sin mi marido
no sabemos lo que pueda pasar tenemos
miedo de estar solas
a pesar de sus esfuerzos mehmet y su
esposa no consiguen convencer a sus
hijas
hay cámaras por todas partes los atrapan
enseguida los culpables no pueden
escapar lo puedo observar comparecen
ante los tribunales en cuanto son
grabados por las cámaras
una vez hecho esto
las cámaras de las calles son muy útiles
deberíamos tener más nadie debería
salirse con la suya si roban un auto la
policía lo encuentra en dos o tres días
Si roban o golpean a alguien son
arrestados
Esto no es suficiente el sistema no es
suficiente hay que mejorarlo y
corregirlo eso no es suficiente para mí
[Música]
pero hay una cuestión en la que todos
están de acuerdo antes de la cappé el
velo era símbolo de ignorancia o
ruralidad hoy las mujeres con velo
pueden ir a la universidad ser
funcionarias o incluso alistarse en el
ejército
[Música]
en el pasado el velo era un problema
un gran debate
si uno se ponía el velo no podías ir a
ninguna parte afortunadamente
erdogan ha rectificado la situación eso
es innegable rompió el tabú
una encuesta reciente muestra que hoy en
día menos de uno de cada diez turcos
piensa que el velo es un tema de debate
la hija menor de isanur llega hacia el
final de la cena Después de terminar sus
estudios le gustaría ser profesora esta
joven de 17 años es la primera de su
familia que no lleva velo
[Música]
en nuestra familia no existe esa presión
me puedo cubrir si así lo deseo a partir
de cierta edad Yo también me pregunto si
llevaré el velo pero no tuve presión
familiar soy libre de decidir
[Música]
va al instituto y manjative
originalmente estas instituciones
formaban animales pero el akp las abrió
al resto de estudiantes a los que
incluso anima a matricularse al igual
que otros seis millones de Jóvenes
turcos que votarán por primera vez el
próximo mes de junio la joven solo ha
conocido a un hombre al frente de su
país
tengo una idea sobre por cuál partido
votaré Pero prefiero guardarmela para mí
el voto de los jóvenes será decisivo
Perdón que ya ha permanecido en el poder
más tiempo que ningún otro hombre en la
historia de su país pretende imprimir
aún más su sello a Turquía en unas
elecciones que caen en el año del
centenario de la fundación de la
república
[Música]
Gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de boleto de vuelta que en esta
oportunidad nos llevó a Turquía vimos
las dos caras de un mismo país luego de
la evolución del akp y también conocimos
la percepción que los turcos tienen de
su presidente recuerde que puede
Ingresar a nuestra página web France
24.com para ver esta emisión y las
anteriores Hasta pronto